irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
espagne qui frappe à ta porte et ému par
son étrange et sauvage beauté castille
d'oled capitale des carpes et annie
juché sur une colonne de granit offrant
trois de ses flancs otages
jaillit des montes universal est ce le
tage qui très vite l'aragon pour
étreindre tolède
non
reste le fortifications arabe la porte
du soleil tout un passé au deuxième
siècle tôt les tomes des roms
après la bataille de guadalest oled
appartient aux morts au 11e siècle une
dynastie indépendante cie établi et
alfonsi s'en fait sa capitale
mais au xvème siècle expulsions les
familles morose et juive amène la
déchéance de la ville ce qu'elle est
devenue aujourd'hui ceux-ci architecture
arabe rue est la grande pente rue aline
la surprise ruelle où l'on entend
résonner si on a un tout petit peu
l'imagination le bruit les duels sa
cathédrale à la triple couronne
privilège papa l'envoyer être plus
courants elle a été fondée par alphonse
6 sur l'emplacement d'une église
primitive transformées en mosquées
achevée au xvème siècle et aujourd'hui
centre de l'église espagnole sont
l'archevêque était prima d'espagne
musées musée il en faut dans les villes
ils savent garder les souvenirs et nous
les présenter d'une façon attrayante
ici des mosaïques romaines des margelles
depuis arabe
des chapiteaux des colonnes
tolède a aussi sa tour carrée son
enceinte craignait qui datent des goûts
et des morts
et ça porte surmontée d armes de charles
quint roi d'espagne et en france
d'allemagne du led un bébé
la tour jeanne domine
et voici ce qui reste de ce qui fut une
des richesses de kool aid la manufacture
d'armes
elle a été fondée au xviiie siècle elle
a employé des milliers d'ouvriers
l'armurerie tolède remonte bien plus
loin elles étaient déjà connues ou temps
de la république romaine
c'est sous la domination arabe qu'elle
atteint son apogée pour disparaître au
xviie siècle et renaître de ses cendres
sous charles iii en 1761 louise des
castillo mètres arme caste yen est
chargé de transmettre la tradition
jusqu'à nos jours elle nous est parvenue
intacte
e
m
long travail de patience et l'adresse
amour entre le faire le feu et l'homme
je
lacrampe y est secrète c'est un bain
d'huile et d'eau et la quantité et le
temps il faut sont toujours inconnues de
lopou flammes
pourquoi faire une lame fine fine et
robuste
voici celle les conquistadors avec
incrustations de filigramme or et argent
pl coffret objets précieux autre secret
de tolède
et la maison du greco d'origine grecque
élevé à venir ces carrières appartient à
l'espagne il arriva à tolède en 15 100
il substitue rapidement sa palette
vénitienne pour prendre sa palette
austère où dominent éternellement le
blanc le noir
le vermillon le lac rouge l'offre jaune
et quelques bleus
quelques-uns de ses chefs-d'oeuvre
saint françois
la bière
et jean plus frappants chef-d'oeuvre
l'enterrement du condor gaz qui lui fut
commandée par l'archevêque de tolède
pour l'église saint thomas
cathédrale
visage de l'espagne
oh
et ce visage ne serait pas fidèle à lui
même sans ces images procession où se
mêlent la croyance la légende la
dévotion la violence et le fanatisme
les représentants des confréries
religieuses sont toujours présents elles
nous font nous souvenir que ces
processions avait un but sinistre celui
de conduire le supplicié sur les lieux
de son supplice et les rues de tolède se
prête parfaitement à ce mystère
8 légendes telles celles ci vieille du
16e siècle
même jeune fille fiancée à un capitaine
le voyait partir cours la guerre des
flandres il s'était juré de s'attendre
il en avait fait le serment devant le
christ de las vegas
les années passèrent elle resta fidèle
lui la jeune fille porta plainte contre
violation du serment heureuse époque
seul le crucifix pouvait évidemment
témoigné le juge le greffier demande et
aux crises de las vegas de dire la
vérité à la troisième demande qui la
besa le bras droit prend dinan je le
jure
c'est pourquoi un christ en espagne a le
bras droit non plus si fier
on
mater dolorosa
et les soldats en ôta tic armure romaine
pour enterrer dieu
et puis mon dieu vous est ressuscité
pour nous montrer le chemin de l'espoir
c'est ce que nous disent ces cloches
et nous sortirons de tolède par sa porte
pour aller vers notre destin
à
iman chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours d'alain roulier et de
solange péters montage pierre michel
rein script charlotte de la salle sont
annick v10 illustration ce